Zach wrote to me yesterday saying hey
David I live in Israel and I saw you
tonight on Israeli TV and this was on
channel 10 it was a segment about Donald
Trump sort of coalescing the
anti-semitic vote around himself let's
check it out this is this particular
clip is from when Donald Trump went to a
room full of Jewish business people and
said all of you people obviously
negotiate right which had such
incredibly stereotypical anti-semitic
undertones that segment was used last
night in Israeli channel 10 news let's
check it out kill them you deem Donald
Trump has built his campaign on
prejudice and paranoia strumpets vehicle
oh well zombie Carabella beam sheesh
nimesh be still deep in you deem
chidiebere mortem hava you demon I'm a
negotiator like you folks we negotiated
one renegotiate deals we've some of us
renegotiate yields i would say about
99.9 is there anybody that doesn't
renegotiate deals in this room this room
negotiator you might as well have said
listen like you I know how to do people
down in negotiations that have
experienced that firsthand people have
used that term in front of me and it
didn't go that well after that none of
those people are still my friends desi
ghee Agha manana kisses an image of
Hillary Clinton what uh with uh what was
a star of david over a pile of money
calling her a corrupt politician with
eva case it cuz I that's no got a lot of
people asking me how did channel 10 in
Israel get this especially since it's an
older clip I have no idea no one
contacted me uh but it it's uh I'm
thrilled that they use the segment of
the show and I have no plans by the way
of filing any copyright strikes against
channel 10 in Israel they use this under
fair use I would argue as part of a
broader peace and with peace and love I
have no problem with them using this but
in exchange we have to get the music
that they used so yeah we can play that
during the show that is dramatic music I
really do like that okay so first time
on Israeli TV pretty cool thanks for
Zack for sending that to me